everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
do some UI work so we're gonna try to
stay as close as we can within material
design principles and we're working on a
search page so I've been looking at
probably what's the most well known
search page with lots of filters and
that is Amazon search now well-known
search in general probably be Google's
search page but I think for our use case
we're gonna have filters that are closer
to what Amazon uses so we can take some
inspiration from Google search page as
well but at least for the desktop
version I think we're gonna be better
off going with something similar to what
Amazon uses even even the mobile as well
I think the way Amazon has done it is
pretty nice so on my other screen I'm
trying to get these examples up of what
what both amazon and google do for their
search filters and sorting
for some reason it's not let me resize
this window here we go
okay let me let me get n grok started
for you all so if you're not familiar
with angra this is going to allow all of
you to use this link to see the website
that's being hosted locally you can
inspect it in your own dev tools you own
your own machine as we're going so
that's in the live chat I'll probably
paste it again in a few minutes as more
people join looks like we have yeah we
have about our average a number of
viewers in here now so I'm gonna switch
my screen and get started I do want to
let you all know especially those you
who watched my last stream but I tried
to do at home and the quality wasn't too
great that I did upgrade my internet
service to the highest level I could
possibly get at my my house and I'm
hoping that will help and I also messed
around with a lot of the settings I
looked at what a bunch of other people
were doing I had some help so you know
like the YouTube live stream or the 24/7
free code can music stream that's going
now so the guy who does that
pretty sure Matthew I think his name's
Matthew I hope I didn't get that wrong
but Matthew worked with me for like an
hour we were trying to figure it out so
I've done all that I think I can at this
point to try to get it to work so
hopefully the next time I try to do it
from home which may be tomorrow or
sometime next week
it will work I'm aiming to get to get
720p resolution I think that'll be high
enough so that everyone can see the font
I don't really think it'd be possible
for my current setup to get higher than
720p so I'm hopeful for that I really
would want to have better quality for
you all
also I'm working on a project let's get
this scatter us started should we do you
know normally we do a mobile first one
but I think I'd rather start off with a
desktop search because the mobile first
one is going to add the mobile version
of our search is going to add a bit more
complexity and I don't know that I want
to deal with that right now I think it'd
be better to go with the more simple one
and then add the complexity of having
dropdowns and things so that's what
we'll do Sooni I'm working on a new
project if anyone is interested let me
know I'll have a github repo up soon but
I put some details on Twitter yesterday
or the day before or so and I bought a
brain-computer interface headset so I
don't know if you all have ever seen
this but you put this headset on it's
kind of like headphones and it it
monitors your brain activity your
brainwaves and you can tell you know
certain things about what's going on in
the brain like are you more relaxed or
you know are you more focused things
like that so my son my oldest son who's
eight years old he has
obsessive-compulsive disorder all right
he has some issues where you know he'll
just like get he gets himself all worked
up about something and if it gets bad
enough he just like he can't get out of
this this mentality where he's just so
frustrated and upset so my idea is that
I'm gonna take those brainwaves
and I'm gonna use some of the work that
Alex Castillo has been doing so you
could check out Alex Lee on his Alice
Castillo dot IO check him out on Twitter
you know he's been at a bunch of
conferences but he's done a lot of work
with being able to interpret the signal
from those headsets and and bring it in
and manipulate use that for with
JavaScript's so basically pull it into a
website or a web app so I'd like to do
that same thing and Alex is actually
offered to help me with this which is
awesome and I want to bring it into a
very simple JavaScript game that's going
to help my son recognize when his brain
is starting to get into that pattern
where it's he's going to get all worked
up to recognize that early enough so he
can get himself out of that and also to
help him train his brain to be able to
get himself out of that to calm him down
so the idea is just very loose right now
but the idea of the game is that certain
mechanics in the game are gonna be based
on his his brain activity so in order to
move forward in the game and progress
he'll have to successfully calm himself
down so there's going to be a lot of fun
tuning that's going to happen I know
there's God definitely got to be a
balance between like making the game
challenging enough so that it actually
does give him incentive and train him to
you know help correct his thought
patterns but it also can't be too
challenging that it actually would make
him more frustrated so he does get
really frustrated with video games if if
he keeps like losing and losing so it's
gonna probably take a long time but I
think if it could work it could be
really helpful for my son but
potentially helpful for other people who
are dealing with mental health issues
especially with kids adults have a much
easier time verbalizing what they're
thinking but kids especially when my son
was younger you just never knew what was
going on in his head he didn't know how
to explain what he was experiencing so
I'm thinking that this may help so I'm
gonna start with start with my son and
see how it goes so anyway I'll probably
give you you know updates on this as it
goes on I may even livestream some of
the work on it record some of the result
because I think I mean other people
might be interested and you know other
people that maybe you're way more
experienced than me might be interested
and might be able to do more with the
project and help more people so anyway
enough with that project let's get to
our project
that that we're working on today and
that is this search page so today what
we're gonna do is just take these
filters that we have here and this
sorting and we're just gonna move it
over we're gonna move it to the side so
let's see what's side left side or right
side I don't really know I don't know
whether we should do left or right
if anyone has any opinion on that let me
know otherwise I guess we'll just start
on the right side yeah so essentially
this this section here will be split
into let's say a fourth of it or a third
of it will be filters and then the rest
will be search results okay James st.
right side okay we can try that all
right so let's get this into position
first will kind of fill out you know
this basic grid that will have that'll
keep these in there right sections and
we could probably determine like at what
point we need to switch to a mobile view
and then then we'll go get like kind of
a little bit more detail with fixing
padding and things like that
mmm so I talked about the on okay all
right so some of you are commenting here
on on this michael says won't be able to
say until I see what you intend all
right fair enough yeah it's I have an
image in my head but of course you all
can't see that so James asked a great
question how many checkboxes will there
be eventually there may end up being
quite a few yeah definitely more than
three so let me let me pull over from
Amazon here let me pull this over under
the screen so y'all can see kind of what
what they're doing and so you can see
what I have in my mind a bit so I just
did a search for a webcam because I'm
I'm looking
for better webcams for streaming but
they have their refined by section here
and you can click on these different
things but they have them and we may end
up having to do this as well to help the
user they have them in these little
subsections and depending on how many
filtering options we end up having that
that might be a better way to go so
something similar to this and then
Amazon puts there sort by up here I mean
that's the possibility if that's what
the where user would expect it to be and
instead of with the filters then I'm
open to that and then the search bar I
do kind of want to keep the search bar
like maybe at the top so maybe something
more like search bar where it is except
with better padding and not completely
across the entire screen
filters next to the search bar or I'm
sorry the sorting next to the search bar
and then filters down one of the sides
oh cool when Nicky says the Logitech 920
is often used for stream streaming so
yeah I think I was looking at one of
these 920 models so there's some I'm
just trying to determine like what how
good do I need it to be for for
streaming because some of them are
there's one that's you can stream you
can record 4k and things like that
I definitely don't y'all don't need to
see my face in 4k I'm pretty sure all
right Michael says those aren't searches
though the choices anyway when you start
inputting in search bar brings up
choices for departments
much sick as a gold box today on
logitech alright now meeting a lot of
input on the webcam okay so I'm not
gonna read it right now I'm gonna wait
and read it after let me start this
Pomodoro timer so we can get to work
after 25 minutes I'm gonna go back to
the live chat and answer any questions
that you you all may have put in there
and we can talk more about webcams then
but right now let's start with the
search bar all right we'll start with
the first things that we're gonna have
on the page and we'll work our way down
so it'll be search bar first filter
second I'm sorry I keep mixing these up
forget what I just said search bar first
sorting second over here and then
filters somewhere on one of these sides
all right so let's go into our our file
first you can check out the where right
where the search is file so you can
check out the github repo if you liked
the description for this video should
have a link to the repository and let's
go down to where we have that input here
it is here's our search input and we
haven't used the material design style
for testing we just threw in a regular
input so the first thing we're gonna
want to do is go to the material UI
documentation and we're going to grab
some code from there to be able to use
this input we are up and less material
you I came out with a new beta update
within the last two days we are
completely up to date so I did merge
that other branch into master and I
found out after I restarted the server I
did find some things that broke in the
UI so basically
almost everything was fixed by me
changing type to variant that was most
of the work if you want to see
specifically what I change go check the
last few commits and that should give
you an idea of what it takes to upgrade
to the latest version of material UI and
in terms of dealing with breaking
changes luckily a lot of the breaking
changes dealt with components that we
didn't even use so that was good for us
so it should have this open material
nope those are the icons there we are I
always have material UI window open
somewhere okay so this is material UI
next comm so we're using the latest beta
version and actually let's refresh this
see if we get the newest version what I
refreshed it now I can't use this side
but what is going on there we are
okay beta 38 I that's what we're on so
we're in beta 38 we're all up to date
let's check out our components and what
do we have inputs text fields there we
are okay so we're gonna want a text
field there's a search field I guess we
could check out the code for the search
field we're definitely going to need to
bring in a text field so let's pull that
in right now we'll bring in this import
let me zoom in a bit so y'all can see so
we're importing text field
and then we're also gonna bring in we'll
figure out what styles we need see it's
thanks - yeah let's just just pull win
this text field styles we're probably
going to need those and put them here as
of right now my my organization for our
Styles objects is basically just in the
order that these elements appear on the
page might not be the best way to do it
but it's working right now
okay now let's find that we already have
our handle change so we're good with
that
search yeah I'm not sure right now what
is different about the search field it
looks pretty much the same guess we'll
find out okay so we have this input now
and at first I'm just gonna put this in
right above our current input so I can
make sure that we have
all right
you know what let's see we want this to
be a controlled component let's see if
see if that's how they're doing this one
alright let's find that multi-line
that's controlled where is that at
I thought the last time I looked at this
there was a version where they used a
controlled input okay so it is just
value here okay all right that should
work then so we're gonna add whoa not
that so we're gonna add this value here
and we also need this on change here and
let's get rid of this and see what we
have labels search I don't think I need
that
ooh
what is going on fail to save vortex you
what did I just do
shake check
I don't know what just happened
see if they caught our changes right
there we go
Tech soon
she assured us
whoa that's not right
I'm gonna check the lodge house evening
you caught what what I just did what the
heck
okay let's do this I'm gonna grab this
text field I'm gonna copy it and throw
it over here in our file of scraps and
then I'm gonna go to the github repo and
I'm gonna grab the original file so
wasn't let me undo the changes wonder if
I can manually undo undo
yeah I cannot do any of that so we're
gonna grab that file I guess I could
just
Johnson I may have an extra closing
bracket somewhere yeah it looks like I
accidentally deleted some stuff right or
paste it in some things that I shouldn't
have I
yeah I'm not exactly sure what happened
so anyway I'll fix it right now I don't
need any of that stuff that looks good
so I'm just gonna copy the let's see
check box more control for sure they
will check box okay so from here down to
this second form control I think is what
we need let's double-check that we do
have that glasses select value okay I
think that's that's it
tech shield is not defined okay
try this again did anybody catch what
happened what did I do okay
now let's save it okay success we'll
save that time all right now there we
are now I have a search field let's
actually put search out there which
probably not gonna have it like that
so let's do just do our search for
biology okay wonderful
all right cool so it is it is searching
okay maybe maybe since I said it was a
search field it automatically gives me
that X which is actually really cool
very cool all right so we have our
search field step one completed let's
check our time 11 minutes left on our
timer
cool let's see
where we go on okay sort by that's what
we're doing now let's go grab all the
stuff for sort by and first thing we're
gonna do is just move it up here and
then once you do that then we can work
on whatever else we need to make this
look nice and be very obvious to the
user what its gonna do so this was
already put in I believe Nikki was the
one that that did put that in there so
Nikki already filled it in with the
material design style so we won't have
to worry about changing anything for
that so right now you have this whole
floor in control so yep there we are so
we're just gonna take that and remove it
from where it is we're going to move it
up here above okay
we we're gonna move it up here but what
we might want to do though is change
change this form actually on submit and
it's give form results
we don't actually have a submit button
that do we and what is this SVG I'm
gonna take this I'm gonna take this out
and this SVG yeah and I'm gonna replace
the forms with with this form control
okay
all right let's see how that looks whoa
okay so now we have everything up here
in this line and we're gonna fry you to
add some grid stuff here okay
let's check out in material UI check out
our layout stuff and to our graders
I just wanna see what okay a grid
container all right
great containers and grid items it's
been a few weeks since I work with this
and it's needed a refresher on the
syntax okay
so let's just put some containers in
here we're definitely going to want a
container here and within the same grid
container I want to have I guess we
could put everything in the container
let's try to put everything in one grid
container right now and see if that
works so where are we
oops I was there a great great yeah okay
so put it all on the grid
Oh John Hanson that's a good point here
it's a submit function in a form without
a submit button is the enter key okay
I guess that shouldn't be a problem
since we're searching automatically
there wouldn't really be a reason to hit
the enter key the user could hit the
enter key and it would seem like it
worked anyway
but cuz since we're just automatically
searching so I guess I should be alright
if anyone has a different reason why we
should keep what we had before and let
me know all right let's import grid as
well
and as this component starts to get
larger it's probably going to be a good
idea to separate it out into multiple
components but what we're building it
will keep it all in one place once we
get it to a place where it looks good
this is you know pretty much what we
want then we can separate it out I find
as long as it's not too large it's
easier to have it all in one spot
you know while you're making it at least
for me and I suppose that's we can grab
this container do we already have a
container class I think we do content
container okay so this should work so
let's see what it's done we need to add
our our grid items in now is this gonna
look silly without it okay so we just
need to add grid item and then we can
add in our values for what we want we
like how many rows we want this to take
up
so let's put around
I'm just gonna put these in and not
really worry about the values for now I
just want to get it all in there
all right and I apologize if I'm gonna
be a little off today I started to get a
headache I actually started to get
really bad heartburn and a hag right
before the stream so I took some pain
medicine to try to get rid of the
headache and it's starting to come back
again so I'm gonna do my best
I want to see how these I better type in
something legitimate let me see how
these results look okay I mean this is
make sense this is exactly what I just
told it to do so now let's go back and
give this some legitimate values for ya
all right about two minutes I'm gonna
come back to the live chat and answer
answer all the questions for now let's
go in here and give let's set this to
twelve am I using let me see what I'm
using am i using a twelve grid let's
inspect this or second
okay it looks like it is great lease for
now that's just good so you want alright
let's go with let's go up here to our
search bar let's give this so out of 12
let's give this 9 and that can stay
three and then that's down here let's
take this grid and let's move it down
below here and we'll keep this at three
and we'll make this a nine and that'll
be alright cuz things ought to line up
there we are so these will line up and
these will line up okay hopefully now
you see a little bit a little bit more
about what I was going for so the
filters will be here right sort here so
it doesn't really look like much right
now I think we still have some work to
put in for this but this is about what
we're going if you think the filters
would definitely look better on this
side let me know we can do that that
won't really be a problem for now my
timer just went off so I'm going to take
a five-minute break
I am yes take a drink here
so as always I'm drinking my G fuel I
put up a post on Instagram with my G
fuel in it and I tagged G fuel in it and
I gave him a little hint that they got
an opportunity for me to be a
spokesperson if they want it so they
didn't get back to me though not yet
they you know they might be busy maybe
they'll be back to me later this week
alright oops let me start this
all right so five minutes I'm going to
try to get through as many questions as
I can alright
Nikki says hey excited for f1 to start
again this weekend cool I'm not really a
racing fan I'm not anti racing but I
just don't often watch it but I'm glad
you're excited for it Nikki says I hope
Daniel Ricciardo Rick Ricky Ardo said
does well cool again I'm not really
knowledgeable about racing but good luck
Daniel but Matthias says hi Jess you
love your stuff keep it up thank you I
appreciate that
and I plan on keeping it up for as long
as I can
as long as it's beneficial to you all I
will keep doing this James Ross says is
the new project of beard no I've
completed that project I that was our
last project the butyl probably be
leaving soon it's it's gonna start
getting warmer now despite all the snow
that that a lot of us got yesterday it
is gonna start getting warmer and then
beards aren't as fun Santiago says
greetings from Venezuela
the game sounds like a good idea oh
thank you thank you so that was if you
weren't here at the beginning I gave
kind of my plan for one of my side
projects so you can if you're interested
in my side project that has to do with
brain human interface our brain computer
interfaces check it out on the recording
you just go back and watch the first
like 10 minutes let's see I'm scrolling
down to find some questions alright so
here was some discussion about what the
best camera is for streaming that I
should get so if anybody has any
experience with webcams
please let me know your opinion
basically the logitech 920 series seems
like something that I should look into I
don't the only thing that I ever really
do is like images of me right like doing
this just like I'm doing now so I don't
know what quality I really need I saw
one
that's a pretty good deal on Amazon I
think it was only like 40 or 50 dollars
which was discounted from the normal
price and it could do you can record in
1080p but you can only stream in 720 I
think that would be okay I mean I don't
let me know if you think that quality
would be alright for me I I mean really
I'd rather not spend a ton of money I'm
I don't make any money from streaming so
it's it's not like an investment for me
it's just would be a little bit better
quality so anyway if you have any
experience with webcams especially if
you're streaming with them please let me
know what what you all think is a good
one preferably one under $100
okay Daniel says Daniel Frank says I can
personally vouch for the nine 20 and it
has worked in my enterprise for three
years straight everyday use Oh excellent
that's exactly what I wanted that's
that's really good advice I mean you
know you you can read all you want
online you can read reviews but it's
much better to like really talk to
somebody you know so I appreciate that
Daniel oh michael says about search bar
stuff I like the Amazon drop-down
incorporated into the search bar then
the autofill entries into the search
results not sure how hard that is in
react okay so is that somewhat like what
we're what we're doing that the filters
are kind of with the search results and
then the drop-down is kind of with the I
know it's not as closely with it as on
Amazon but I think that's a bit what
we're going with it that general idea
michael says or to save space especially
on mobile have a multi-select drop-down
that auto fills with returned available
filters yeah that's what I'm planning on
doing on mobile so definitely basically
the only thing you'll see right off the
bat on mobile is the search field
everything else will be in a drop-down
yeah it'll be in a multi select
drop-down maybe I'll have the sort by in
its own drop-down as well I don't I
don't want to get too crazy and have too
much stuff you know because the Mobile's
you only have limited space on mobile so
we'll see how much space we can get but
that's basically what I'm a what I was
thinking of going with okay I am almost
to the bottom of the live chat so let me
see I don't think there's that many
questions left so I may go ahead and
even though my timer and off I might try
to get just these last few you just
don't want to keep you all waiting with
for the answers for too long
Jason Lee asks what's the timers for is
this a freelance project the timer is
just to break up our time here so that I
don't spend too much time talking or too
much time coding we get a nice kind of
break in between I also use the Pomodoro
timer just to break up my day it's not a
freelance project this is a I'm a
front-end developer work full time
salary for a university
let's see
software dev says it is interesting that
you've got tags like grid control and
form control is that pre compiled and
normal HTML tags and the JavaScript is
within the HTML all right Nicki says
it's not really HTML it just looks like
it alright so this is a good segue back
into the code here so let's let's go
over this yeah let me go over this now
then so let me start our coding timer
and the first thing we'll do is just
kind of do a quick recap of what we've
done to go over some of these these tags
so software dev is asking about these
tags so basically if you're not and I'm
not assuming software dev it that you're
not familiar with reacts but anybody out
there that's not that familiar with
react all of this here looks a lot like
HTML but it's actually not it's it's JSX
and what this is is is syntactic sugar
on top of JavaScript functions to create
Dom elements so really what what these
will break down into is a JavaScript
function that's going to create a select
few and create these items within these
select fields but that's really hard to
write if you use two HTML it's kind of a
pain to write all these functions like
think of like continually writing like
document dot create or get over IDE or
creative you know what I'm saying it's
it's a lot so this makes it easier we
can write basically what looks and acts
pretty much like normal HTML so when we
write things like this like this grid it
ends up turning into something else so
we can see what it turns into here so we
have this div with a class of Mui grid
right in the classes are get kind of
crazy but then with any we have a field
set all right we have a legend a div
labels spans more
SVG's inputs right so all of that comes
from just adding in in that case the
select in these menu items within within
this I'm sorry that was the checkboxes
we're looking at from just adding in
this grid form control form labels and
checkboxes so each one of these is a
separate component that exists in a
separate JavaScript file somewhere
within our project and in particular
most of these exists within the material
UI package so it sits in our node
modules folder so yeah so it doesn't
exactly behave like normal HTML and
there's a lot more to it obviously but
it's kind of hidden away and it lets us
you know have markup that's that's
cleaner and we can still have control
over it by passing in these properties
so these props will change things and
give us some versatility for those
components so hopefully that was a
decent explanation of a little bit of
how react works and hopefully it
answered your question if it didn't let
me know and then after this Pomodoro
session then I can go back and try to do
a better job okay so if I didn't get to
your question right now we'll get it to
it at the end another a few there at the
bottom that I didn't get to and okay so
let's let's work on these
let's move the label for short by up
because right now this this looks kind
of odd side by side so we have the
labels kind of opposite so let's just
switch that around now it should be
something easy and it I think it'll look
a lot nicer for helper text
okay see what that does for us here we
are which we still have some padding
issues here let's see well what's going
on so right now we have our grid
container our grid item form control the
text field must be what has the extra
padding because right we have grid form
control here right so it's the same
let's see what kind of class text field
the sealy I'm going on here on our on
our text field styles with margin left
margin right width okay we don't have
any extra margins or padding margin or
padding happening okay all right let's
then look look into dev tools and see
what's going on okay
form control the form control here let's
see do we have a difference here alright
this form control it is giving us class
name for magenta for Michelle
interesting
so this has a in a div within the normal
form control div that says page text
field so let's check out here what we
have going on and we don't have that
happening here okay
all right let's see our michael saying
isn't the search field tax built into
the search element is the select a
material element i thought it wasn't a
cheer you i let me double check yeah
that's definitely a material element so
that's not default select behavior okay
let's see
all right so the style of that margin
that's the 16 pixel margin here and 8 at
the bottom and that's coming from margin
normal so why don't we have it's just
it's entirely not creating another it's
creating this item type that's really
odd
that's really odd I John Hansen saying
add a line items baseline on that
wrapping div okay we'll try it out in
dev tools first and we should have
yeah
all right not making a difference
the furthest if you say in this this
whole container
okay I'll shout out then whoo baseline
okay so all right so we have a line
items baseline going now
[Music]
why is it a listener
so we have this gap right here how do we
have this gap CSS is a fun mystery
sometimes art where's my gap coming from
is there any difference here
we have the salon items on here
that's about it
join us if I took out that first
baseline that I had it I was that's what
I was thinking and I think it was here
and I must have accidentally set it to
left but that's it I mean it's that was
where I added it in so it's gone now
it's just weird
anyone have any idea why why it's doing
this excuse me I'm gonna get another
drink here well while I ponder this
problem
okay
hmm let's play with let's play with this
i baseline center looks pretty good
obviously these don't this doesn't look
good and this looks okay right now but
if there were only a few items it would
take it down well I guess it it would
show up in the middle so that wouldn't
look good but what we can do is we could
change it might be easier to just do it
on here let's let's try this for a
second let's take out this align item
center here and then how do we do it
aligned self Center okay so if you're
using flexbox which I believe the grid
system is this grid system and material
UI is based on flex locks so it's a
little misleading because it's calling
it grid but it's not using CSS grid it's
using flexbox correct me if I'm wrong
what it looks like from the CSS that
everything's based on flex so what we've
done is the standard for everything is
still in place but on this one
particular element we want to change the
behavior so we use a line self-center
and then it can change is this alignment
to Center and it doesn't affect any of
the other ones does that make sense so
let's go with that and let's add I'm not
gonna make a class I'm gonna add this in
right on that element because right now
it doesn't see it look like we're gonna
have to repeat that so
let's go over here to our grid and we're
gonna I'm gonna style and then in react
when we want to put a style on something
where we're actually going to make a
JavaScript object so the first set of
curly brackets lets us start writing
javascript within this JSX so we've
switched from kind of like the HTML like
mode and now within these brackets were
in JavaScript mode so we can write
pretty much the same way that we would
write normal JavaScript and then so now
I'm creating an object within there and
now I can put the the style in there so
we're gonna do align self and we can
camp we need a camel case that right
because this is JavaScript if I put a
line - self it's gonna think I'm trying
to take a line - self ok so aligned self
and then the next one we're gonna make a
string so everything unless it's just a
pure number needs to be a string on on
the right hand side of the colon and so
we're gonna say Center and now when we
save this will show up like an inline
style one here so let's make sure yeah
let's hit refresh just to verify we'll
do an actual page refresh
and there we are so you can see we still
have this aligned self Center and I look
at it does that still look a little off
to you that actually still looks a
little off let's see if we can squish
this together to get a better look at uh
you know what it's a it's not really
that off I thought it was farther off so
you can see here whoa you can see here
our lines are just a bit off and when it
pops up is search field it's a bit off
but I I'll live with that for right now
what do y'all think I mean just for the
sake of moving on I think we can live
with that
so I mean one reason is the screens
never going to be that small showing
these side-by-side like that will switch
to a mobile version that'll be different
so when it's that far apart I don't know
I'm okay with it for now
it'll probably bother me for a while to
refresh that again what's going on here
the styles are definitely messed up here
you know what
see if that doesn't mean no
there we are okay
I think what happened was the changes
yeah I pulled in all the changes but I
forgot to run yarn or NPM install so I
didn't get the latest version of a
material UI so that was that was why
these the size was all off okay all
right now we're good and for these
filter results for now the only thing I
really want to do is decrease the
padding in between these I just think
it's a bit much once we get more filters
in there then we can take a look and
really see like do we need you know how
do we need to organize these but for now
let's just decrease the padding a bit
let's see do we still we like that color
you know what I also want to change I
may not do it today I don't think we'll
have time today but I like to change it
so that if you click this it only does a
search again if there's actually some
text in that search field so I don't
want it to just give you like
automatically search when there's
nothing in the search field Yusef
Ashford and grukk link yeah I'll paste
it in there again I pasted it earlier
and I forgot to paste it again
here you are
alright Michael criolla st. for now add
it to do yeah actually that's not a bad
idea let's add some to dues in here do
more precisely is that he spoke
precisely do you all ever just avoid
using a word you don't know how to spell
because you don't feel like actually
verifying how it's spelt and then what
else did I just say we were gonna do oh
okay
with the search so let's let's puts up
here in the filter filter filter filter
filter by category
okay all right now let's check out
what's going on with our padding here
and I just want to see where that all
that Patti is coming from it looks like
it's not actually padding its its height
so we have margin right margin left my
Flex photo in the middle so where are we
getting that height from mmm maybe it's
in here
height 48 all right if we drop that high
let's see what our computed this is okay
so why is our computer height let's
check back here at Santa Cruz I just 48
I mean that that does make sense
interesting okay let's check this out
where are we getting night
okay so that's on the button you know
icon button which we don't directly have
control over here huh menu item that's
not it
oh yeah geez okay so within our check
box we're gonna have to look at the
material you add documentation to see if
we can change that I realized why they
do that they want the checkboxes to be
easily clickable by someone's finger or
thumb but if we're on a desktop we don't
really need to worry about that so yeah
so John just I just see in the live chat
John saying the same thing that that is
48 pixels is pretty standard for being
clickable so I'm willing to go below
that standard only for large screens I
do want to keep that standard for
smaller screens so actually my Pomodoro
timer just ran out so I think we'll keep
it for now and I'll consider whether we
should have right now it really doesn't
matter like I mean this is fine my word
is if we get a lot more items it's it's
gonna be it's just gonna be too much
it'll be overwhelming like the length of
all the options here so I guess this is
something we'll revisit once we get more
content here and and then we'll see what
we need to do so
let's commit these changes let's go in
our terminal here and for those of you
who are new to the terminal and new to
get and github I'm gonna just explain
what I'm doing while I'm doing it so I'm
in the terminal I'm in the folder for
this project and I'm gonna do a git
status so if you have get installed on
your computer you can use the command
get so the git status is telling me that
two files have changed the search jazz
file that we've been working in which we
expect the change
and then this yarn look and that's
whenever I went in and ran the yarn
command it changed this luck file so
that's also expected even though we
didn't directly do anything to lock file
which generally you shouldn't directly
do anything to your luck well anyway so
now that we verify that these are the
files that we expected it to be changed
we can do in this case we're going to
run this command called yarn CM now this
is probably going to be unfamiliar if
you haven't watched any streams because
this is kind of a custom setup I'm not
we didn't make it all custom but the
command whoa
we never added it ok get add I need to
add first I need to add these files to
the staging area so get added and then
if I add a little dot a little period
after that it'll just stage everything
everything that changed so if we do a
git status you can see now these have
changed to green and they're in the
staging area such as changes to be
committed now we're gonna commit with
yarn cm all this is gonna do this is
just kind of a layer on top of the
normal git command so it's just gonna
walk us through how to write a good
commit message and then just run a git
commit on that so we're gonna say it's a
new feature and let's say update sirs UI
and there are no breaking changes and I
don't think this affects any issues now
it's gonna do a bunch of automated
testing which this potentially depending
on how good of a computer you have this
could be a much longer process we did
get one warning here since it was a
warning we still pass then we can still
do this but I believe this is due to our
update
to the newest version of material UI so
for right now it's a warning but at some
point we should check this out
and see like perhaps this just isn't
used anymore so we still have it in
there and it's kind of a little
confusing here to react so we'll see see
what that is but not not an emergency
type of thing so now that we have our
commit message we're gonna push this up
to github so if you're using github in
addition to get which a lot of people do
you'll want to make sure you sync up
everything you've done locally on your
machine with github so that other people
can see what you've done and you can
access that on other computers as well
and they can too so we're just gonna do
a git push origin since we're on the
master branch it will automatically push
to origin master if we wanted to push
this to a different branch we could have
done get push origin and then put the
name of that other branch that we wanted
to push to and that's it all done so now
everything we've done today all the
updates are available now on the git
github repo the link is in the
description to this video you all can
use that do whatever you want with the
code it's entirely free and open-source
and have fun with it okay let me go to
the live chat now and answer as many
questions as you all have if you do have
any more questions please put them in
the live chat now if you for whatever
reason don't want to put your question
in the live chat but you still like to
ask it just reach out to me on any
social media platform might the link to
my github channel is in the description
and from there you can see on the home
page of my channel all my links to all
my different social media things so I
don't always answer right away but I do
try to get back to everyone that asks me
a question at some point
as she says hi I learned C++ and Java
right now I am in free code camp hoping
I will understand your topic okay great
I am yeah hope that you get something
useful out of this feel free to ask you
so many questions as you need to I'm
sure if you've already learned C++ and
Java that you'll be able to pick up on
this you know pretty quickly
okay Michael just checked out the
Logitech gold bucks on Amazon so they
don't have cams just just mice keyboards
and speakers alright well thanks for
taking that out for me I do appreciate
that that question which book is best
for beginners beginners of c-sharp true
beginners I I can't answer that I I have
almost no experience with c-sharp I've
just I've done a little bit when I've
had to for this job so I don't really
know if anybody else has experience with
c-sharp and oh so many good books please
let us know in the live chat Newshour
asks what motivates you I think there's
a lot of different factors that that can
motivate me so it's it's not usually one
thing all the time you know depends so
obviously the overall you know
motivation for me is to provide for my
family right I mean that's like baseline
you got to take care of your new your
basic needs before you can take care of
anything else right so just making sure
that my family has enough to eat you
know I can put them through school have
a house form and things like that right
but I could really do that with any job
so for specifically for we're coding but
motivates me is number one I really I
like to do this I think it's fun are
there moments that are frustrating oh
absolutely
do I sometimes I have to work on
projects that aren't as fun yeah it
happens but overall in general I really
like this when when I'm home and on like
the very rare occasions when I don't
have any kids at home like coding is one
of the things that I think oh I'm just
gonna code like a side project to do
something right so I it's it's like a
hobby but I get paid for it okay so I do
like it also and I hope this doesn't
sound bad but can
competition motivates me right I like I
want to be better I don't want to be
better in the sense that I enjoy
watching other people get beat right
like this is you know one-on-one
competition no I want everybody to get
better but like I enjoy being better
myself so in the healthiest version of
competition where I want to be the best
but I want all the competitors to be at
the top of their game right so we can
all get better together so hopefully
that makes sense right like there are
some people who want to win no matter
what and it doesn't matter to them like
if their opponent gets the flu and they
win they're just as happy well that's
that's not me right I'd I wouldn't be
happy about that I want everybody to be
really good and then push me to be
really good too
so I don't know I think that's that's
just an exciting thing to just try to
find out like how much better can I be
in building things you know and
ultimately being better in web
development means making things that are
more useful to people that are more
easily accessible that make their lives
easier that that look beautiful you know
that's that's what better means so I'm
not gauging success in terms of
motivation you know really buy money in
terms of providing for my family money
is you know obviously what I need to
gauge that by in addition to being able
to spend time with them but then in
terms of being motivated by wanting me
better it has almost nothing to do with
money it's you know is what I'm making
is a quality work you know is it really
helping people so anyway I hope that
wasn't too long of an answer for you all
but those are kind of some of my my
motivators and sometimes when you're
just down you got to make up your own
motivators like or you gotta have help
so like you got a drink an energy drink
or give yourself like little things like
okay if I every time I finish a new
Pomodoro session I'm like eat a bite of
chocolate or do something that that you
want to do
I've actually done it before we're like
every time I had a five-minute break in
my Pomodoro session I would watch five
minutes of a Netflix show which is silly
to watch five minutes at a time but like
that was my reward to get me through
that that little portion I think at the
time I was putting in like crazy hours
so it's just like anything that I could
do to just keep going so anyway those
are some of the things that motivate me
and on any given day I might be more or
less motivated by one of those things
but you know head together it really
keeps me on track and passionate about
what I'm doing let me know what you all
think is motivating for you I'm really
interested to hear what motivates other
people so let me know in the chat or in
the comments the video or even in social
media somehow tag me and it or whatever
you can even DM me if you want let's see
yeah okay yeah why why don't you join
any company well I mean I'm not I work
for a university so I guess that counts
as a company right John Hanson says for
mobile just use a modal four filters and
sorting yeah I could I'm either gonna
use a drop-down or immaterial you I you
can actually have two different drawers
come out so I could have the one drawer
come out for the main menu and I can
have a drawer come out of the other side
the right side for the filters so I just
have to figure out what what button
they're people gonna press to get to
those filters that might be kind of cool
I have to remember that Michael says a
bunch of new people in here today that's
a good thing yeah definitely for
everyone that's new here welcome I
really appreciate you watching I know
that towards the end here we've kind of
dropped off so I wish I would have
acknowledged you all earlier when there
were you know about twice as many people
in here but if you stuck around if
you're here you know thank you so much
for watching and I really want to be
receptive to what you all want so any
advice you have for me or any questions
please let me know I'm I'm usually super
nice about everything so I'm cool with
criticism you know try to be nice but if
you must be mean I'm not gonna cry at
least on camera but but anyway I'm
serious I want to make this better so
let me know what would you all want you
know what kind of things you like what
kind of things you don't like
it's
not too many questions left let's the
noble and savage says woot hi all hey
how's it going
thanks for joining us
ooh John Henson says use a negative
margin left on the input titles this
won't impact on the standard clickable
area okay I think I like I like that
idea well I'm not gonna do it right now
but when it comes time for us to really
start getting detailed on this as we get
more of the filters on here yeah I'll
definitely want to mess with this too to
see if it looks better you know with
them being closer that's a good trick
Nino's says do you know when y terminal
button the env what's I'm not sure what
that is wasn't supposed to be end I
don't know in Python can't be active
from the terminal in Visual Studio code
I have no idea I I haven't done anything
with Python for years so I really have
no ideas I'm sorry Michael says I've
been playing around with graph QL slash
react for a day or so so when I think
like I understand what's going on watch
out you might have a Harsha 2.0 alright
I'm looking forward to it yeah
unfortunately I had to stream later
today except other stuff going on so I
know harsh it's most likely sleeping at
least I hope you sleeping it should be
it's really late where he's at
so I'm gonna try to stream earlier
tomorrow if I can and I know he's busy
right now with school so maybe he can
join us it for those of you who don't
know Harshit he's a veteran I guess of
the channel and very outspoken in
helping me when I'm doing something
wrong but it it truly is it is helpful
michael says but i'm three times his age
so that's kind of creepy
that's yeah Harshit is only 16 and
actually when he was fifteen when he
started watching the the streams and
very smart
I think he's gonna he's gonna be a very
good programmer if he keeps going at
this pace he's already good see Carlos
says Jesse can you explain the yarn
command on git oh yeah for sure let me
explain that that again so what we did
here on the terminal let me go up and
show you so instead of doing a regular
git commit we did yarn CM and then we
got these little prompts that basically
writes a commit message for us and then
the commit actually happens so let me
scroll down I wonder if you'll be able
to see it yeah so here's where the
commit happens so you see this is the
commit message that we actually got feet
right for a new feature because we said
yes we selected that option and then for
our message we put an update search UI
and we said no to everything else so
this is our message so it creates a
message for us depending on what answers
we give to the questions so it's just a
little additional thing that helps us
make a nice uniform commit message all
right Michael says I'm out it's been fun
hey see you later Michael thanks for
joining us
so that's what we're doing if you want
to know more about exactly what's going
on behind the scenes I would check out
the package.json file what's here that's
a package.json yeah so here's our
package.json file and down here we have
this cm and that does a get CZ
and we're using committees in so
checkout committees in and if you want
to know more about how to do stuff like
this and how to set this up and I
believe there was a poor quest for this
so if you check through the pull request
for this project on github you'll find
one that has to do with this and there's
probably some more info on on how to use
it there Carlos is awesome thanks for
explaining I always have a hard time
thinking what to put in a commit with
what I'm doing
yeah me too for sure so this does help a
bit it helps you kind of think through
okay what am i what am I doing here
so yeah it's definitely a really cool
addition to the project
okuu Carlos says awesome class had a
great time learned a lot I'm glad I'm
really glad you know join us again if
you can some time and love to have you
back
javabat says would you recommend using
reacts with es6 + typescript i don't
know that i can recommend it because i
haven't really used it I've looked at
other repos that use it I haven't in
terms of type script like es6 with react
for sure for sure use es6 with react
it's it's a lot better if you take
advantage of what's available in es6 if
you're not familiar with es6 it's kind
of the newer things that are available
to use with javascript sometimes called
es2015 I believe yes 2015 is is actually
the official name for it but most people
will say es6 in terms of typescript
though I don't know enough I don't have
enough experience working with it to
really tell you if it would be better
it would probably depend on your project
honestly to determine like how much
benefit would you get out of it if
anybody else uses tight script with
react and can give it a better answer
that question please let us know in the
chat
boov on us asked this session go on
every day yeah Monday through Friday I
try to do a session every day I don't
always get to do a session every day but
that's my goal
viral only says hi thanks for the
session you're welcome thanks for
watching
John Hanson says I just realized that by
using the array function find it totally
isn't supported at all an internet
explorer good that's up I'm of the
opinion that we're not doing our users
any favors by supporting outdated
browsers especially browsers that are so
outdated that it's security risk to the
user we're enabling them to keep doing
things that are bad for them right to
keep doing these bad security practices
they probably don't even know it but if
more sites I mean this may be
controversial but if more sites just
wouldn't work for them at all maybe it
would spur them to say hey something's
wrong with my computer or my browser and
actually learn more about it and update
if we keep supporting all these old
browsers then we're just enabling
hackers or whoever to take advantage of
people who know a little bit less about
computers instead we should educate our
users with a little message or something
saying please update your browser for
your security and for a better
experience also I think we've got to
think about like what is the reason
behind why we want to support these
older browsers right mistakenly we may
be thinking like oh we want to include
everybody and we want everybody to be
able to experience our site I mean
that's a good thought but you know at
the bottom of it at the root of it
especially if we're one if we're selling
something
are we just supporting older browsers
because we want the most number of
people possibly able to buy our product
or do something online now I'm not
saying that's what everybody does but at
some point somebody higher up is
probably thinking that like more people
coming to our site equals more money so
we want as many people as possible
without really thinking like okay but is
that with what's best for the user so
that's that's my reasoning I'm not
trying to be mean by not supporting
older browsers but my reasoning behind
not supporting older browsers is
genuinely being concerned that
people have no idea what kind of danger
they're putting their themselves and
their computers in by using such
outdated browsers when there are so many
security safeguards in the newer
versions anyway I know I've talked about
that before in the stream so if you've
heard me say that before sorry for
repeating myself but that's my view on
it I will say this if you do it like
that and you don't support other
browsers it's it's probably good to have
some sort of check for a browser and
display some sort of message to let the
user know what's going on if the site
just breaks and doesn't work that's not
a good user experience at least if you
have a very polite message explaining
the situation to the user then you are
actually providing some help so we'll
have to remember to put that in this
project or else I'm gonna sound like a
big hypocrite so let's plan on doing
that I have done it for some of my
projects I admit I don't always remember
to do that and sometimes I do end up
supporting older browsers occasionally I
don't do it a lot sometimes I just do it
kind of accidentally because build tools
like a lot of build tools take care of
that for you but anyway aah-ha-ha I'm
gonna get move on Noble and savage says
I met someone today that uses IE there's
a lot of people that use IE on campus
here that I run into always amazed John
Hansen says there's a lot of elderly
people still using Internet Explorer 8
yet somebody on campus was using
Internet Explorer 8 and had a hard time
trying to use some of the sites that I
built and finally realized that they run
Internet Explorer 8 and that was the
problem
javabat says do you have something like
a set of CSS classes which you are using
as a basis for every project yes
something like that so depending on what
we're doing if we're doing a react
project we're always using the tear UI
which comes with its own set I mean it's
big it's like bootstrap or materialized
but for react projects if we're doing an
on react project we use materialized CSS
and then we also have some classes that
we just kind of carry over to new
projects we usually use sass and we have
some sass variables for different colors
and things that we carry over so we do
have a style guide that really needs
updated right now so I kind of don't
even want to give you the address to it
because it needs updated so badly but
that also is the idea behind it is to
include some CSS that you can reuse on
on other projects and and make all the
websites will have the same kind of like
standard look and UI so that users you
know they don't have to relearn out your
UI works for every different site you
know it shouldn't be like that and
within one organization there should be
some standardization you know for the
sake of lessening the confusion of the
users and for brand identity purposes
let's see John Hanson says Internet
Explorer is at 2.8 percent worldwide oh
I'm glad and I'm glad it's it's only 2.8
percent
Java bats also says SVG's are always a
problem for me on Internet explorer
interesting I'll have to check that out
I haven't to take the truth I don't
really test on Internet Explorer very
much anymore so I just haven't noticed
if my SVG's are working John Hansen is
talking about says inline SVG's have
less problems on IE maybe that's why I
do like
use inline SVG's whenever I can Java
says thanks for the answer oh yeah no
problem no problem
alright cool I think I got through
everything if I miss your question for
some reason just put in the comments or
send it to me some other way and I'll
try to give you a good answer if I can I
do believe I'll be able to stream
tomorrow not sure what time yet I'll let
you know tomorrow morning at some point
and if you subscribe to the free code
camp channel and turn on notifications
you'll get notified whenever I do a live
stream I also do live streams and videos
on my own channel so if you're
interested you can subscribe and get
notifications on that channel as well I
I'm gonna get ready to put out a new
video soon because it's been since the
beginning of March since I've done a
video on my own channel so it's coming
up soon if anybody really really wants
me to do a video on a specific topic let
me know somehow within the next day or
two because I want to get a video out
here soon
let's see other than that I do announce
on Twitter and usually on Instagram when
I'm gonna stream so whatever method you
prefer to get your news please you know
follow me on those places and that's the
best way to find out what time I'm
screaming yeah alright that's it for me
thank you all again for watching and for
being involved in the chat and for all
your help as always and I'll be back
tomorrow until then have a wonderful day